like a lot of people gamification when
it comes to training and working out
means training like an RPG which is
something I've talked about before but
in different context you'll have like a
fake Avatar and an app or maybe a
journal and as you train you'll level up
their stats and some people find this
motivating problem is though I think
this only really works in the short term
and the issue here is that the
motivation is still extrinsic the
training itself is not motivating
rewarding you're training for an
external goal and if you're willing to
level up the stats of a fake Avatar
wouldn't you be more willing to level up
your own stats so to me the key is to
make your actual training fun turn the
actual training into the game itself
so the problem with a lot of training is
that it's so rote and repetitious and it
doesn't require any Focus whatsoever
it's not cognitively engaging and here's
the difference it's like with work you
get work that is like zombie work
answering emails sending messages these
are things you can do with your brain
Switched Off versus creative work that
engages you consciously you need to
focus on that's what's engaging that's
what keeps you focused and that's what
you need in your training and that's why
something like sparring like rock
climbing like hand balancing even can be
so much more engaging than standing on
the spot and just curling partly this is
about the density of information coming
into your brain and information doesn't
have to mean numbers and letters it can
mean things like gradients and angles
and speeds this is why trail running for
example where you're running on uneven
ground finding new routes jumping over
Crags and gaps this is so much more
engaging so much more interesting and so
good for your brain compared with
running in a straight line on a
treadmill that's completely flat
there are many other ways you can create
a more sensory Rich training experience
for example doing pull-ups from tree
branches or throwing logs rather than
using the perfect flat and round bars at
the gym so how can you implement this in
your regular workouts well obviously you
need to introduce more variables whether
that means being on a balance board
which you're not going to do with heavy
weights but it has a time and a place
whether it means training at an unusual
angle using something like a lizard
crawl and that brings us to the next
thing that's really important for
staying cognitively engaged in your
training and that is novelty so you see
this when you play with a cat with a
laser pen move the laser around the
floor and the cat will show some
interest but it'll go wild when you
suddenly speed it up or stop the
movement entirely the reason for this is
that the brain loves making predictions
and as it tracks an object which is
something that we've evolved to do it
will try and predict where it's going to
move when it gets this wrong this is
called prediction error and that's what
activates a part of the brain called the
substantia Negra this as it happens is
the starting point of many dopamine
Pathways in the brain so in other words
novel novelty and things that you can't
predict send the brain wild with
dopamine this is why sparring is great
because you can't predict the movements
of a partner this is why sports are
great because all the other people on
that pitch you don't know what they're
going to do and it's why curling away
once again isn't very engaging because
you're doing the exact same thing over
and over again with no variation
whatsoever there are lots of ways once
again that we can implement this into
our training with the trail running
we've seen you're exploring new areas
and each time you find a new area you're
flooding it with neuroplasticity
producing neurotransmitters
what this basically amounts to is
learning the brain is built for learning
a lot of people think of learning as
boring because they associate it with
sitting in a classroom but playing
computer games or learning new moves
this is learning as it was intended with
an immediate feedback loop and this is
one of the things that's important it's
something that game designers build into
their games in order to make them
addictive each time you try you get an
immediate reward or an immediate fail
State and this is one of the issues
again with a lot of conventional
training is you don't get that feedback
loop you're just repeating the same
movement over and over however if you
perform a new movement or if you really
focus on the technique even on something
more basic more fundamental then you can
get that instant gratification so
practicing calisthenics for instance as
you try and do a handstand each time you
fail you get that incentive to try again
and each time you manage to hold it for
a while you get a flood of
neurotransmitters to reward you for that
success and this is why I personally
find hand balancing and calisthenics to
be such an enjoyable way to train but
you can get the same effect from
something like powerlifting whether it's
a squat whether it's a deadlift don't
just go through the motions focus on the
Motions on perfecting the technique and
really playing with them and as you do
you'll find it becomes much more
rewarding and much more addictive as
well
with this though there is a kind of
Goldilocks zone there's a point of
difficulty that's ideal for keeping you
in a flow State again this is something
that game designers know well you need
to make sure that the game is difficult
but not too hard if it's too easy it's
boring if it's too difficult then it
doesn't have enough Challenge and it's
not stimulating same with your exercise
make sure that you are trying hard don't
just go through the motions but at the
same time don't push yourself too far
before you're ready stay in that
Goldilocks zone and you'll stay in a
flow state
jumping rope really is a perfectly
gamified and implicitly motivating form
of training for so many reasons for
starters you get that immediate feedback
leap if you make a small mistake then
you're gonna stop skipping right away
you want to have another go and see if
you can do it better at the same time
it's really easy to get into a really
satisfying Flow State and you're in a
constant state of learning not only is
you're learning new skills which is
really fun and rewarding but even just
the basic skip you'll learn to skip
faster with fewer mistakes and this
again is really motivating it's the kind
of thing you don't want to stop doing
and all the while you're getting fitter
and stronger today once again I'm
sponsored by Crossroad who in my opinion
make the very best jump ropes out there
they're incredibly well made but today
I'm here to talk about something even
more interesting
these are their amp handles or amp
handles basically they connect to the
crossroad app via Bluetooth and then
this allows them to track your
performance not only counting your jumps
as you're skipping but also giving you a
breakdown of your performance afterwards
you can see your average speed for
example and you can see your power
output and you can see how you're
performing over time and improving and
once again this is going to give you an
additional motivation not only in the
moment as you're able to follow along
with the guided workouts of which there
are over 2 000 but also over time as you
see yourself gradually improving
depending on how you perform the
workouts then also personalized to your
level and this again is perfect for
keeping you in that flow state for
making sure that the difficulty remains
absolutely spot on there's also a 60-day
trial period so give it a go if you
don't get on with it you can send it
back no questions asked and if you use
the link in the description down below
and enter the promo code bioneer then
you'll also get 15 off of your purchase
so yeah check it out and a massive
thanks once again to Crossroad perfect
example of what we're talking about
today
another thing that game designers will
use in order to make their games more
compelling and interesting is the rule
of cool and this is what it sounds like
if something's cool then you should do
it and I think this should massively
apply to your training I come to places
like this I feel myself crawling around
in a VR headset in town and people might
think that guy looks like a bit of a
knob but what I'm going to try and do is
create a cool visual I'm trying to make
it interesting and this applies during
training as well sometimes I I don't do
that but I'll do things like drop out of
pull-ups and things just for my own
Amusement because something looks cool
and it feels cool then it's just more
exciting and engaging to do you're
playing Metal Gear Rising and taking
down a bad guy jumping from missile to
missile we can't emulate that quite but
we can certainly do more interesting
things with it climbing a tree or doing
lizard crawls or doing push-ups in the
rain it's just far more exciting and
interesting
and another thing to consider is
incorporating an element of
self-expression because self-expression
and the freedom of choice is also really
important for doing something creative
that's really going to be rewarding
so don't go through rope movements throw
in a little bit of ad-libbing as well
another simpler option is to put on some
music the right music makes everything
more awesome
so to summarize if you keep trying new
things if you make sure there's lots of
information lots of stimulation if you
keep learning and keep the challenge
right if you allow for self-expression
and make sure that you follow the rule
of cool then you can ensure that the
training itself is intrinsically
motivating that it's addictive that you
can't wait to get back in the gym and
train some more when you accomplish that
then the gains will come so if you found
this video useful and interesting guys
if you did then please leave a like and
share around that helps me out immensely
thank you so much to Grant Stevens today
for filming and demonstrating some moves
once again you guys know to visit his
channel I'll leave the link in the
description down below
and guys if you like this kind of
training this kind of wild Outdoors
training that's more sensory Rich whilst
at the same time training the body for
more vectors than you could possibly
emulate in a more sterile environment
then you might be interested in
something new I've got for you a new
print book called adaptive training by
the time you watch this it's either
coming out very soon or it's already
released it's from mango publishing the
same as my last print book and this one
goes really in depth into why the body
is built to adapt to its environment
rather than just to respond to training
I actually includes a lot of training
programs and introduce some new Concepts
such as Black Box training so go and
check that out if you're interested I'd
really appreciate it I'll leave a link
to that in the description down below as
well either way guys thank you so much
for watching this one and I'll see you
next time bye for now